en este vídeo vamos a practicar más cómo
se plantean los sistemas de ecuaciones
lineales a partir de un problema escrito
en realidad no vamos a terminar
resolviendo lo pero si gustas puedes
terminarlo por diversión sin embargo nos
vamos a enfocar en plantear las
ecuaciones aquí nos dice laura usa una
mezcla de granos con tostados oscuro y
ligero para hacer café en su cafetería
ella necesita en total 80 kilogramos de
granos de café para su siguiente orden
los granos con tostado oscuro cuestan 3
pesos por kilogramo los granos con
tostados ligero cuestan 2 pesos por
kilogramo y ella quiere gastar 220 pesos
en total
y el número de kilogramos de grano con
tu estado oscuro y el el número de
kilogramos de grano con tostado ligero
que ella quiere comprar ok con base en
esta información que nos acaban de dar
pausa el vídeo e intenta ver si tú
puedes proponer un sistema de ecuaciones
lineales vamos a tener dos ecuaciones
con dos incógnitas
y l y en teoría podríamos resolverlas
para encontrar el número exacto de
kilogramos de tostado oscuro y ligero
que el aura debe comprar pausa el vídeo
e inténtalo
ok vamos a intentarlo juntos voy a
subrayar que oh es el número de
kilogramos de grano con tostado oscuro y
l el número de kilogramos del grano con
tostado ligero y también subrayar lo que
nos dicen ella necesita en total 80
kilogramos de grano de café para su
siguiente orden entonces lo que dice es
que el número total de kilogramos de
tostado oscuro más el número total de
kilogramos de tostado ligero debe ser
igual a 80 kilogramos entonces el número
total de kilogramos de grano con tostado
oscuro más el número total de kilogramos
de grano con tostado ligero debe de ser
igual
80 kilogramos este número de kilogramos
más este número de kilogramos debe de
ser igual al número total de kilogramos
y ok ya tenemos una ecuación con dos
incógnitas veamos si podemos obtener
otra después nos dicen los granos con
tostado oscuro cuestan tres pesos por
kilogramo los granos con tostado ligero
cuestan dos pesos por kilogramo y ella
quiere gastar 220 pesos en total y con
esto que tengo subrayado aquí de color
azul podemos plantear otra ecuación si
no las planteado ya en tu sistema de
ecuaciones observa si puedes hacerlo
ahora observa si puedes plantear la
segunda ecuación pausa el vídeo
ok la forma de pensar es que sólo
tenemos una expresión de cuánto gasto
ella en granos de tostado obscuro y
cuánto gasto ella en granos de tostado
ligero ya sumar estas cantidades tienen
que ser igual a 220 porque eso es lo que
ella gastó en total entonces cuánto
gasto en granos de café obscuro entonces
será el número de kilogramos de granos
de café con tostado oscuro entonces
pondré
y nos dicen que cuesta tres pesos por
kilogramo
así que multiplicaremos a esta o por
tres ok
tres pesos por kilogramo por el número
de kilogramos de granos de tostado
obscuro esto es lo que se gastará en
grano de tostado oscuro y si a esto le
sumamos y ahora nos preguntamos cuánto
se gastará el grano con tostado es
ligero bueno primero compra el número de
kilogramos con tostado ligero entonces
voy a poner aquí a él ok
y nos dicen que cuesta dos pesos por
kilogramo
entonces si multiplicó a dos pesos por
kilogramo por el número de kilogramos
que tenemos con tostado ligero entonces
esto es cuánto gastará en total un grano
con tostado ligero y si sumas estas dos
cantidades nos tiene que dar lo que
compre en total con grano de tostado
oscuro con lo que compre en total con
grano de tostado ligero y eso nos tiene
que dar una cantidad de 220
y ya lo tienes tenemos un sistema de dos
ecuaciones con dos incógnitas
así que ya podríamos ir y resolverlo
pero si quieres hacerlo tendrá que ser
afuera de este vídeo porque el punto
importante de este vídeo es entender
cómo puedes construir estas ecuaciones
con base en la información del problema
con base en estas restricciones que
vemos arriba típicamente cuando intentas
plantear estas ecuaciones existe una o
dos oraciones que se enfocan en una
ecuación por ejemplo esta primera lo que
nos dice es hey la suma de los
kilogramos de los granos nos da el
número total de kilogramos y existe otra
oración por aquí otros que se enfocan en
en este caso la segunda ecuación en este
caso es el precio del tostado oscuro
el precio del tostado ligero es igual a
la cantidad total que ella piensa gastar